why do you
[Music]
[Applause]
recorded sound is everywhere
but it wasn't always this way
before 1857 it was impossible to capture
lost to the passage of time enter
Edwards Leon Scott de Martin built
we'll just call him Ed
was a French printer and Bookseller
running a humble shop in Central Paris
in the 1800s
now he was no scientist but had big
aspirations to become an inventor
whilst proofreading a physics textbook
Ed stumbled upon some diagrams of the
human ear
he wondered if a camera replicated an
eye to record an image how about some
sort of mechanical ear to record sound
to paper
with the help of instrument maker
Rudolph Koenig Ed began building a
device
he called it the fan autograph
the device had a speaking cone which
caused a sharp pin to vibrate
etching patterns onto a suit covered
piece of paper
Ed thought that one would be able to
read the paper squiggles like written
text
in 1857 his device was patented
the concept was pretty ingenious at the
time but it was far too difficult to
make out any words from these squiggles
the fanatograph never caught on and was
doomed to obscurity
Ed tragically passed away in 1879 with
no knowledge that his recordings would
ever be heard
across the Atlantic a young inventor was
Making Waves of his own
Thomas Edison invented the phonograph in
1877 a similar device in which the sound
was recorded to a tinfoil cylinder and
his device allowed playback
Edison became an International Celebrity
hailed as the inventor of sound report
fast forward to 2008. scientists
realized that the microscopic cameras
they used in particle physics could be
used to scan obsolete recordings without
damaging them further they were now able
to play back Ed's recordings for the
first time
one of these was a snippet of the French
folk song
originally thought to be sung by a small
child they found the correct playback
and realized it could actually be a toy
signal
it is now considered to be the earliest
recording of a recognizable human voice
predating Edison by 17 years
he inadvertently created the first ever
recorded sound that could be replayed
and it took the rest of us 150 years to
realize
make sure you like subscribe and share
with friends